all right let's get out and take a look
at the clouds man it's a beautiful sky
right now we've got clouds passing
through temperatures are in the 60s and
some 50s outside the valley outside the
fringes some neighborhoods like
summerlin the lakes mountains edge
you're in just in those mid to upper 50s
50s at sunrise mountain and nellis this
morning where we've had some of those
northeast breezes here are your
headlines so we still have some clouds
mixed with sunshine today but i think
we'll have more sun in the afternoon
temps in the upper 70s so the start of
november is a little unsettled with the
clouds moving through then we're going
to get onto really a lot of sun later in
the week watering schedule remember that
changed yesterday to the winter schedule
you only get that one assigned day a
week so make sure you know which group
you're in that tells you which day you
should be watering and sunday still off
limits and we change our clocks this
weekend we finally fall back to standard
time that happens sunday morning at 2 am
so change those really important clocks
the ones that don't change themselves
looking around the country cool chilly
showers even some snow showers headed
towards the east coast a few snow
showers around denver all that heavy
rain on the coast yesterday that moved
into the north bay and around the bay
area in northern california that's kind
of ended but there is another system
already into the pacific northwest so
we've got clouds moving through had a
little clearing now we've got more this
morning but behind that i do see a lot
of good sunshine today upper 70s for
highs yesterday at 80 so down just a few
degrees and then the rest of the week
wow full-on sunshine and some warm days
80 degrees for thursday 80 again for
saturday might even do that again on
friday so a very mild warm start to
november first week
staying above normal and no rain in the
forecast so john heather really nice and
mild